au début ce ne fut qu'un cri il ne
passera pas pas au pays de la
gastronomie
il s'est bien sûr le hamburger deux
tranches de pommes avec au milieu une
cinquantaine de grammes de viande hachée
grillée quelques oignons cornichons
feuille de salade et sauce mayonnaise
venus des états unis le hamburger est
finalement passé imposante au passage le
fast food les repas pris sur le pouce
tenant du titre le hamburger est
aujourd'hui talonné par les gastronomie
du monde entier qui se reconvertissent
avec plus ou moins de bonheur dans le
sandwich avec canadienne d'origine
le hamburger diététique sans pain made
in italy la pizza qui se consomme
aujourd'hui dans la rue venu du sud est
asiatique
le pâté impérial ou n'aime se mange sans
baguette lapita le pain rond qui règne
sur tout le bassin méditerranéen
s'habille sans sourciller de steak haché
ou carrément se consomme en version
originale comme au liban salades
crudités et mouton grillé
méditerranéenne aussi la merguez
s'adapte très bien à ce nouveau contexte
[Musique]
quant à la gastronomie française elle a
perdu une bataille mais pas la guerre
et de ressortir d'abord les armes
traditionnelles le croque-monsieur les
croissants jambon les feuilleter divers
et même de contre attaquer avec la
franquette des baguettes vient française
fourré au poulet basquaise aux épinards
à la crème ou au boeuf sauce piquante
[Musique]